problem number 32 a scale drawing of a
horse is shown below that's the horse
I'm probably not helping you much at
this point what is the actual height of
the horse in inches from the hoof from
the hoof to the top of the head well
they made a little scale for us this
distance right here is 8 inches and then
they measure this scale multiple times
so how many times are we going this
distance we go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so the
horse is 9 times this distance which is
8 inches which is equal to 72 inches so
that's how tall the horses in reality
which is what it's like 6 feet tall 33 a
shipping company has 25 offices that
shipped 60 thousand packages last week
the offices were opened six days and
used 80,000 kilowatts kilowatt hours of
electricity which pieces of information
given above are necessary to find the
average number of packages shipped per
day last week so let's think about it
they didn't ask us they didn't have well
they did they didn't ask us anything
about the electricity so we definitely
don't need that information and they're
saying the average number of packages
shipped per day last week they're not
saying per day per office last week so
we don't need to know how many offices
we just need to know that 60,000
packages were shipped last week and the
offices were open 6 days so they
operated for 6 days so we can figure out
the answer the answer is obviously
10,000 but they're not asking us that
they're asking us what information do we
need we need we need the total number of
packages shipped last week and we need
the number of days that they were that
the office was open so what choices are
that the number of offices no we don't
need a number of offices because they
didn't ask us per office the number of
packages and the amount of lectures you
know this has nothing to do with
electricity the number of packages and
the number of days opened during the
week yeah that's what we use the number
of packages in the number of days
open during the week the number of days
open
during the week in the amount of
electricity now this had nothing to do
with the electricity so our choice is C
problem 34 a landscaper estimates that
landscaping a new park will take one
person 48 hours if four people work on
the job and they each work six hour days
they each work six hour days how many
days are needed to complete the job so
you could literally you know if one
person takes 48 hours how much is four
people are going to take one-fourth as
long so 48 divided by 4 is going to be
equal to 12 hours 12 hours right if four
people are each working 12 hours that's
the same thing as one person working 48
hours assuming that you can divide the
job up in that way so these four people
are going to take 12 hours all working
simultaneously and they each work six
hour days so they're going to work a
total of 12 hours right because there's
four of them so they can take one-fourth
the time but they're only going to can
only do 6 hours per day so it's going to
take them 2 days to work their 12 hours
so it's going to take 2 days 2 days to
complete the job and that's all we have
on that page